hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are continuing our journey
on the Paul Morphy saga and we are
continuing the match Samuel Standish
Bowdoin versus Paul Charles Murphy and
we've left it off after showing three
three games from this match but we are
going to show a few more before we go to
Murphy's match against mr. Barnes and
then of course to his match or no match
against the Howard Stanton or Staunton
as some of you said that I should
pronounce it but before we check out
this game I would just like to mention
that if you are only now joining us in
the poll Paul Morphy saga we've only
started basically we've only just
started I think so far there are like 28
videos so I will put a link to all of
the videos from the saga in the
description below so you can join in if
you're interested and also I would just
like to mention that our Ghana Torino
made another video regarding the well
basically it's a it's a fun short video
which is basically an intro for the my
podcast with Hikaru Nakamura do check it
out the link to it will be in the
description below it's the first thing
you'll see so do check it out pretty
pretty wild stuff but now getting back
to this game it's it's a great game
because the Morphy gets a terrible
position straight out of the opening and
then he has to suffer but it's very
interesting because it's morphe so
Bowden
goes for efore now morphe replies with E
5 we have nine three nights the c6 and
Bishop to b5 and morphe goes for the
Berlin defense Knight to f6 not for a
six more fees defense and Bowdoin goes D
for the immediate strike in the center
morphe capture some d4 in now see five
now this is a very rare continuation
today but it is still played nowadays
only now after d5 you will most likely
see Knights the e4 or in some rare
occasions maybe nights to g4 but Knights
the d5 is a move that was never played
again after this game and with well with
good reasons as the knight is very
vulnerable and the fight which Bowdoin
will show so here at Bowdoin just
castles and the Morphy also wants to
continue his development so he plays
Bishop to c5 he wants the castle of his
King to safety
and well finish development sort of and
here at c3 now the asking do you want to
grab another pawn and further help why
develop pieces now there you could go
for some like D captures and c3 here but
it would be it would be kind of silly
because the knight on d5 is hanging so
instead morphe just castles to safety
and now a seek capture Sun d5 boarding
gets a very strong Center attacks the
bishop morphe retreats it stability' b6
maybe to e7 was a bit safer as a white
has plans of going Bishop to g5 after
the Queen but okay Bishop to c4 now
Boden loses a tempo he already played
with the bishop but the knight doesn't
really have all that many squares here
and you have to be very careful and not
to lose a piece here for example if you
just move the knight back let's say you
go Knight to e7 you get d5 and that's a
problem now this Knight has no squares
this is covered by the knight and the
Queen card the knife covers this and if
you go something like Knight the a5
white would just move the bishop let's
say Bishop to d3 and next move before
just wins apiece so it doesn't really
help you if you try something like
Knight characters here at the sort of
guard before then there's just Bishop
captures and h7 completely winning kink
a person I g5 with the with the
well-known mating attack after new king
moves queen h5 and so on or or Queen to
d3 with with the same idea so after
Bishop to c4 Morphy has to be very
careful morphe defends the night instead
of moving it sunlight CTE 7 but Bowdoin
continues in great style Bishop to g5
just pins the knight again there's the
threat of Bishop captures since this
night will not be able to recapture and
again you have to be very careful for
example h6 with the idea that if there's
moves you're gonna play g5 and so on is
met with Bishop captures on d5 and now
after H captures the Bowdoin had Knight
captures on g5 planned and now again or
blacks position is terrible especially
if you go after the bishop then just
queen h5 wins the game on the spot
there's no defense against this you have
to give up the Queen just to prolong the
game so after Bishop to g5 we have
Quinta yet the strongest move
and now now finally you can start eerie
maneuvering these nights and rook to e1
by Boleyn it's a good move
and finally h6 now you can play this
Bishop to h4 and now Knight to f4
preparing to shift this night either to
g6 or maybe to d5 depending on on what
white plays so Bowden continues
developing we have Knight to c3 and now
Knight to f5 by morphe and okay morphe
was able to get out of the mess but his
position is still very shaky however he
is threatening the bishop on h4 but
Boden doesn't care Bowden goes Bishop to
b2 he attacks the knight on f4 so morphe
retreats knight back to g6 now creating
a double attack on the bishop on h4
but Bowden still doesn't care Bowden
just goes Knight to e4 and it's a really
really nice idea he's offering more fee
or full peace for example if Knight
let's say Knight captures on h4 you're
gonna recapture and then the I mean the
position is lost for black now however
it's especially lost if you capture the
night here do you see what both and had
in mind even pause the video and try to
figure it out as it's quite quite the
idea while I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it
congratulations on spotting the fork and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it's Knight to f6 check this
checks the King and forks the Queen and
now if you don't want to lose the Queen
you have to pick up the knife so after
GG actress Queen captures on h6 and now
there are a lot of dangers here for
example it's very hard to defend rookie
3 to g3 just wins the game on the spot
you cannot bring the knight back to help
out with the defense because the Queen
can just capture it the bishop prevents
the F pawn from capturing it's
impossible to defend here if you try
something with bishop characters on d4
to guard the e3 square you still get
rook to e4 with the same idea of just
rook going to g4 and if you try
something like f5 to prevent the desgin
then just work a person h4 and black is
still getting checkmated so amore has to
be very careful here but morphe is not
one to be tricked easily so morphe just
goes d5 he counter-attacks in the center
now with an attack
against the bishop in the night so
Bowdoin is forced to capture our pass on
here so II capture Sun v6 in now Queen
to d7 again a very important move as
Knight to f6 check now does pick up the
Queen
so Queen to d7 by Morphy and now Bowdoin
still doesn't care now if this was some
sort of a modern game white would say
okay I attacked fiercely but now it's
time to cool off a bit maybe Bishop to
g3 maybe go Bishop to e7 make the trade
happen and e7 however Bowdoin continues
the attack with Knight to e5 like like a
madman and now okay your queen is under
attack the knight is under attack so
Knight capture series a threat as this
is you you still have the issue of a DF
for not being able to recapture so more
of you of course has to capture the
night so he goes in the night captures
on e5 we have D captures on e5 and now
he grabs the bishop with Knight captures
on h4 and Bowden continues in great
style however it's a bit different now
morphe again goes for Knight to f6 check
checks the King Forks the Queen and
morphe has to capture the knight so G
captures but now there's a difference
because if Queen captures on f6 now then
morphe has queen g4 and not only do you
stop any rookie for ideas but you're
also just threatening checkmate so in
order for white to prevent this you
either have to play something weird or
let's say Bishop to f1 to defend this
but now just Knight f3 check the pawn
cannot recapture cannot capture you
you're gonna win the roof so after King
here you're just gonna pick up the rook
and after real captures you can go Queen
g5 for the Queen trade and you're of
course doing much better
so after G captures on f6
of course Bowden did not go for Queen
captures on h6 he saw that this doesn't
lead to anything
instead East six he prevents the Queen
from guarding the g4 square and now is
planning rook to e4 to g4 and hopefully
can still recover just capture on H six
more to capture Sun d6 it's it's it's a
great move and now you have to either go
Queen captures on h6 which bottom plate
or you could go for something like
characters on f7 check first but then
King
you seven and you no longer have the
option of going here so Bowdoin captured
on aged six but now more free just plays
a bunch of captures on e6 he says
there's no no problem here problem is if
Queen captures on h4 then you can just
go rook F to e8 and you can bring your
King to safety you've freed up some
squares here but we were also just up a
full piece so yeah I know no
compensation for white here no no real
compensation at least so after Bishop
captures on e6 Bowdoin captured on e6 he
did open up Morpheus King up a little
bit with F captures on e6 and only now
brings the rook into the game with rook
to e4 threatening some some nice ideas
however morphe just brings the knight
back with Knight to f5 and now the queen
is under attack and you don't really
have all that many plans here rook to g4
check was played but after King to f7
Boren saw that there was no way to
continue the attack and it was in this
position unmoved 24 that Samuel Standish
Bowden resigned the game and yet another
victory for Paul chars Morphy I just
realized I miss wrote Charles but okay
well I mean what are you gonna do so a
great victory for Paul Morphy and we are
going to continue the match for a little
bit I think I'm gonna show two more
games from this match before continuing
before going to the match with mr.
Barnes so here you resign as there is
nothing more to do of course you could
continue with a check like the Queen h7
check but after King yet there's no
continuation here this night just does a
wonderful job of defending and if you
try something like rook e1 with maybe
ideas of Queen captures then just Queen
d2 is sufficient you can even allow this
recapture skin can move and there's
still nothing here the knight just does
a wonderful job and well this is now a
threat just tweenty one tweenty one
threats of checkmate
it's not possible to continue this for
white so I bought an agrees and he
resigns here so that's another game from
the match board and morphine I do hope
you enjoyed it I would like to thank
Karuna such a nun Donny
Peter Antone Mark
potato max Meyer holster in the William
gull for a contributor to my channel
thank you a lot to really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos serum thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the Murphy saga checking up
on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day and
do check out the video I mentioned the
link is in the description below see you
soon